September is suicide prevention month
and for those battling suicide ideation
there is help out there and that's the
focus of help Hope and action a suicide
prevention Town Hall I had the
opportunity to moderate and it's
available online now joining us to talk
more about that is Rick auraga the
president of health plan of Nevada
Behavioral Health thank you Rick for
joining us today uh why why was this
important to have a town hall meeting
along these lines Kendall nice to see
you again
um the health United Healthcare and
health plan of Nevada partnered with the
American Foundation of Suicide
Prevention as well as the defensive line
to develop and to bring awareness of
suicide and Behavioral Health to as many
people as we possibly could especially
those who are you know silently
suffering
the prevalence of suicide nationally is
because becoming more and more
I guess magnified to say say the least
and in Nevada you know we're 40th in the
in the country right now and in
Behavioral Health we're 50th and so what
does that mean when you say we're 50th
and Behavioral Health of providing
Services of those individuals who are
actually presenting in behavioral health
conditions and so in partnering with
these organizations our goal was again
to bring as much information and
awareness to as many people as possible
and it is really uh really well done and
I so appreciated those who were on the
panels tell people it's broken down into
three parts and and why is that and how
does that work yep um there's three
panels uh the first panel focuses on
youth team
and young adults and it's primarily how
to identify and how to address
those individual behaviors that maybe
recognize that maybe people or may not
be comfortable to address the second
panel focuses on adults and seniors and
Veterans which are experiencing
isolation and again higher prevalence of
suicidality and the focus is more
resiliency and the third panel is
digging into what and how our health
care System our health plan our
community services as well as our
government can provide services and
provide and partner to close that Gap
meaning no wrong door policy if
anybody's having a problem they they can
search and get help anywhere they're
able to seek it yeah and it's an issue
that touches just about everyone in some
respect and I so appreciated everything
that was shared in this tell people
where they can find it and watch it sure
it's on health plan in Nevada take
taking on health and it's actually
highlighted this month because September
is suicide awareness and prevention
month okay we're going to have that
highlighted on our website as well so
people can find that link and check that
out thank you so much Rick for being
here today